gun then mortars machine guns and
cracking tomatoes, it
was just like this, I’m saying
how long I’ve lived here, I haven’t seen anything like this
[music] The
Kiev regime, having been defeated in the
city of Artyomovsk, moved on to carrying out
terrorist actions against
civilians on May 22 of this year after
intense artillery shelling of the
international checkpoint Kazinka.
as well as a number of other civilian objects of the
Voronsky district of the Belgorod region,
units of the Ukrainian
nationalist formation
invaded the territory of the Russian
Federation during a counter-terrorist
operation with air strikes,
artillery fire and active actions of
units covering the state
border of the western military district, the
nationalist formations were
blocked and the remnants of the
nationalists were defeated and thrown back into the territory of
Ukraine where  it continued to
inflict fire until complete
elimination,
more than 70 Ukrainian terrorists were destroyed,
4 armored combat
vehicles and 5 pickup trucks